Я думаю, це класно, що люди щось вигадують нове й стараються якось допомагати армії.
Я думаю, що це безглузда ідея. Як ви собі уявляєте збирання FPV-дрона вдома?
Тільки-но міністр цифрової трансформації Михайло Федоров закликав українців
самотужки збирати FPV-дрони вдома, як у суспільстві спалахнули дискусії та суперечки.
За ними спостерігає й волонтер Олег Таібов. Щоправда, каже, часу на це має обмаль.
Вдень Олег працює 3D-дизайнером, а ввечері допомагає українським військовим.
Нині він збирає свій 29 FPV-дрон, інші 28 - вже на фронті.
Вірю в те, що ймовірно саме цей дрон доб’є якийсь танчик або "задвухсотить"
якогось окупанта. Саме цей дрон, його вистачить.
Спочатку Олег навчався самостійно, а згодом пройшов безоплатний онлайн-курс
проєкту Victory Drones зі збирання й налаштування FPV-дронів і взявся до справи.
Вісім уроків вони зробили, в яких розібрали повністю, як збираються саме ось такі
ударні дрони-камікадзе. В принципі, просто прослухати лекцію,
витратити дві години через день було взагалі нескладно, але й інформативно.
Якщо дійсно є бажання допомагати в цьому напрямку, то більш ніж реально знайти цей час.
Цей безоплатний онлайн-курс уже пройшли понад дві тисячі українців.
А після заклику міністра Федорова анкету на участь заповнили ще близько 11 тисяч.
Серед них - люди найрізноманітніших професій: від айтівців до медиків,
розповідає керівниця Центру підтримки аеророзвідки та засновниця Victory Drones Марія Берлінська.
Тривають лекції в Zoom, де наші інженери просто за руку проводять всіх бажаючих
і розповідають, як можна створювати такі дрони, які насправді всюди в світі
створюють навіть старшокласники. Тому що це "хобійні" дрони.
Зараз ці дрони вимушено використовуються українцями для того, щоб відбивати російську агресію.
Приміром, один такий дрон може вразити російський пікап, а кілька - спалити ворожий танк.
Відео ефективної роботи FPV-дронів на полі бою щоденно публікують військові
та волонтери. І водночас щоразу наголошують: дронів треба ще більше.
Тож саме заради того, аби частково закрити потреби військових,
і створили безоплатний онлайн-курс, пояснює Марія Берлінська.
Проте, каже, деякі українці побачили в ідеї інші підтексти. Наприклад, такі.
Я вважаю, що цим все-таки повинна займатися держава, а не змушувати виконувати народ
те, що має виконувати держава. А не казати в останній момент,
що ми нічого не можемо, то ви самі все купуйте, всі комплектуючі й збирайте вдома.
І хоча автори ініціативи й сам міністр Федоров уже неодноразова уточнювали:
збирання дронів вдома не виключає державного серійного виробництва,
а є радше підсиленням, поки підприємства-виробники налагоджують процеси,
ідею продовжують критикувати.
Тому що це техніка, яка буде використовуватися на фронті. Потрібен якийсь контроль цього всього.
Я вважаю, що це не вихід, бо держава сама повинна визначити, де й як робити.
Більша частина критики була від тих, хто не розібрався до кінця в цій ініціативі.
Адже це було сприйнято як те, що пропонується організувати виробництво
мільйона FPV-дронів на кухнях. Це не так. Зрозуміло, що це не замінить промислове
серійне виробництво. Це не замінить уніфікацію, стандартизацію,
однак це дає ряд інших переваг. Це консолідує суспільство тим, що кожен
може допомагати фронту. Це дуже підтримує, коли людина розуміє,
що саме її дрон працює на фронті й дає можливість рятувати життя.
Втім, авіаційний експерт Костянтин Криволап ідею виробництва дронів вдома
не підтримує. Адже сумнівається в якості таких дронів. Хоча автори ініціативи запевняють:
Для тих, хто реально воює, в них є один принцип: все те, що вбиває ворога,
все те, що ефективне, що дає результат на полі бою, те потрібне, те має право на життя.
Та Костянтин Криволап певен, що відсутність належного контролю
під час виробництва впливатиме на якість дронів.
До того моменту, коли він буде вбивати окупанта чи танк, він повинен бути правильно зібраний.
А для цього повинна бути та комплектація, яка повинна бути для того, щоб цей дрон працював.
А якщо у вас там якісь компоненти не стикуються, то фахівці -
за рахунок перепрошивки чи інших конкретних речей - можуть це виправити.
А якщо ви нічого не розумієте в збірці дронів, то ви нічого зробити не зможете.
Водночас Марія Берлінська запевняє: команда проєкту надає необмежений супровід
усім охочим, а дрони, які виявляються несправними, не викидають.
Одна історія - подивитися ролик на YouTube, а зовсім інша, коли наші інженери
день в день дивляться на цю збірку, дають фідбек, проводять за руку всіх слухачів курсу.
Плюс всі дрони проходять протоколи тестування.
Ті дрони, які потребують доопрацювання, використовуються з навчальною метою.
Тому що якраз є можливість, й ми навчаємо військових не тільки літати, а й базовій інженерії.
Виробництво "народних дронів" підтримує і засновник компанії Drone UA Валерій Яковенко,
хоч і сумнівається в ефективності таких дронів на полі бою.
Це класна ініціатива й це лише початок створення й популяризації ідей
інженерів майбутнього, бо Україна - це країна інженерів.
Нам потрібні інженери, які повірять в себе. І ці дрони, які можна зібрати в себе вдома -
це не те обладнання, яке потрапить на фронт. Це обладнання буде ідеальним
для того, щоб тренуватися з ним та вчитися.
Експерт певен, ініціатива зі складання дронів вдома допомагає знайти
"інженерні таланти", а отже - розвивати виробництво FPV-дронів в країні.
Людям, які збирають свій перший, другий, третій дрон вдома,
легше повірити в себе та долучитися до великих підприємств для того,
щоб збирати дрони тисячами, робити це в режимі конвеєра.
Якщо говорити про цей ринок і про можливість навчання, то зараз в Україні працює
понад 700 різноманітних компаній, що виробляють дрони. І можливість долучитися
до них важлива.
Щомісяця українські компанії виробляють понад 50 тисяч FPV-дронів,
водночас російські - щонайменше вп'ятеро більше.
Тож вільний від основної роботи час Олег намагається проводити в майстерні.
Я люблю порівнювати таку роботу з тим, що як тільки почалося повномасштабне вторгнення,
всі почали робити "коктейлі Молотова". У кожному дворі всі робили "коктейлі Молотова"
й діти приносили пінопласт і так далі. Всі були аматорами, ніхто не був хіміком, але робили.
Й це допомогло в свій час. Так і з дронами:
якщо всі активізуються й почнуть допомагати, це зробить різницю.
Комплектуючі для своїх перших FPV-дронів Олег купував власним коштом,
а згодом офіційно зареєструвався як волонтер. Тепер більшість дронів складає завдяки донатам.
Інколи звертаються місцеві бізнесмени, кажуть: "Нам треба два-три дрони, зробиш?"
Вони надають кошти. Я закупив деталі, зробив дрон. Передав їм.
Середня вартість такого FPV-дрона - 14 тисяч гривень. Це якщо купувати деталі в Україні.
Якщо ж замовляти, приміром, з Китаю, то вийде дешевше, але чекати на комплектуючі
доведеться близько місяця. Також додатково необхідно придбати акумулятор,
це ще близько трьох тисяч гривень. Крім того, знадобляться інструменти для створення власної майстерні.
Приміром, повний перелік із точними назвами, а також посиланнями
на інтернет-магазини, де їх можна придбати, надсилають слухачам онлайн-курсу від Victory Drones.
Потрібен паяльник, потрібні кусачки, якийсь пінцет, тому що це така детальна робота.
І викрутка треба для того, щоб потім це все скрутити.
Своїм досвідом із DW Олег ділиться, щоб власним прикладом надихнути українців
долучатися до виробництва дронів. Адже, каже, кожен виготовлений дрон -
це врятовані життя українських військових.
Дякую, Олег Таібов, за такий "подарунок".
Дякую сім'ї Таібових та всім небайдужим, хто долучається до донатів
і допомагає збирати ці "диво-пташки". Слава Україні й разом до перемоги!